We Begin this morning with hurricane
Fiona which continues to pick up
strength in the Caribbean and is already
blamed for two deaths Fiona hit the
Dominican Republic yesterday with
sustained winds of 90 miles an hour
leaving a trail of Destruction behind it
slammed into Puerto Rico the day before
triggering an island-wide blackout and
extensive flooding today also marks the
fifth anniversary of Hurricane Maria
making landfall in Puerto Rico our lead
National correspondent David Beckner was
there David good morning it's not
looking good
good morning my friend listen you have
nearly every electrical customer here on
the island that is without power this
morning roughly 800 000 people don't
have water we expect it today to be
telling you how the island was doing
five years after Maria a category 4
storm which devastated the island but
instead today on the anniversary of the
meet Maria we're back talking about
another hurricane a category one which
also devastated the island we want to
give you the best view we could
so we got a helicopter it took off
as soon as we landed it was clear we
weren't going to be able to get to the
affected areas by car fast enough so we
got in a helicopter and we first flew
over to a Baja you could see people
standing on cars on the second story of
their homes which were flooded we then
flew over Manatee where you could see
fuel actually running through the
flooded town and then we headed all the
way west to the municipality of onyaska
hi hi once we landed in onyaska we
hitched a ride with Erica Matthias in
the back of her family's truck and they
took us through some of the town's
inundated streets she told us that in
some places the water was up to four
feet deep nice to meet you we met a
woman named Lourdes she's been living
here nearly 12 years they just went
through Maria
and now again
but the important thing is that we're
alive Lourdes jumped to the back of the
truck with us and took us to her home
which she said she helped to build with
her family years ago she's one of 16
children and had just repainted the
house have you ever thought of moving a
flood zone I love living here because I
love my neighbors I like the environment
the only part bad part about this is
this but the storms won't stop I know
other moments later we drove right by
Norma Rivera watching for her neighbors
from the second floor of a friend's home
she grew up in Puerto Rico and just
moved back here four months ago after
spending years away how would you
describe Puerto Rican Pride when it
comes to wanting to live on the island
no matter what
it's fooling out every damn day I work
from home and I hate it
when we left Norma we flew back to San
Juan and we noticed that some of the
lights were starting to flicker come
back on but we're talking two maybe
three percent of customers that are
getting power restored so far so the big
question is in the five years since
Maria have there been any major upgrades
to the electrical grid how are things
now when it comes to the power that's
the story we expected to tell you today
and we will coming up at 7 30. hear the
answer to the question when we went to
the private company hired to handle the
transmission and distribution on the
island and asked them what major
upgrades have been done
hear what they have to say we'll see you
at 7 30. Michelle
David the irony of it all happening all
over again we are so glad you're there
thank you